former teen heartthrob and star of 90210
Luke Perry passed away at 52 after
suffering a massive stroke and dude I
remember watching nine oh two one oh
when I was young it was like the first
show that I got to watch it was called
Beverly Hills 90210 and it was about
rich kids and some poor kids that all
went to school together in Beverly Hills
and um and I remember doing that that
was like the first show were like there
was kind of some you know people were
having maybe sex or talking about sex
and I would sit there and like and up my
whole from my brothers and sisters we
would all watch it I think my littlest
sister wasn't allowed to watch it but
we'd sit there dude and I would be just
erect as hell you know I'll be Wu's the
only TV show I'd someones have to face
the other way and then turn back and
look at it you know and watch because I
didn't want people seeing my body
getting all hard in the middle
especially I had that ap bride that
[ __ ] rocking jock you know I had that
[ __ ] DeMarcus Cousins you know wiener
even as a child I had that big [ __ ]
baby whale you know I had that [ __ ]
that Will Sasso that thick hitchhiker
you know it was like uh you ever seen a
mitten but the thumb is twice as big as
the finger part that's kind of how like
my nuts and wiener even as a child you
know I had that cat daddy and so I'll
you know it make me so nervous because I
would just have on little shorts or
tight you know children's television
pants you know little what were those
things called little whoa you remember
those it was like a onesie and it had a
little trapdoor in the back in case you
had to do with duty real fast or
something in case it was a fire in the
you had to get out of the hole ones he
they had that little fire escape in the
back okay somebody threw a match on the
front of your pajamas and you had to
[ __ ] wiggle out of them [ __ ] they
had that you know the you know that
reverse psychology just a way he could
just say bye-bye
out the back of young short you know
your own that onesie and you could just
you know you could save your own life
but but yeah I remember do those things
and suddenly I get so erect the [ __ ]
rest of the ones you would get real
tight on my body cuz I don't have a lot
of room in that [ __ ] anyway you know I
got that body type I'll [ __ ] fill a
onesie you know but you know I got that
limited neck you know only got about an
inch and a half long neck but I did see
this little neck stretcher thing on
Instagram the other day so I might look
at that I don't want to thank everybody
that sent me links to that as well I had
about 60 people that sent me different
links to that the show 902 1o was the
first show that you as a kid I remember
just seeing just like adult things that
were things that were just ahead of my
things that were happening in my world
you know like I remember like the to get
the kids on the screen there were
teenagers they were in high school even
though they were in their 30s as you
know in real life but we didn't know
that as children and so 9:02 one knows
man it would be on and we would you know
Brenda was about to kiss Ryan or
whatever Ronald and damn bro secondly I
would just [ __ ] me like this and my
sister would just start like her neck
would start shaking for no reason and my
brother but I don't even know what he
would do bruh he would pass out we don't
know I don't even know what was going on
dude I'd have a little thing of Shasta
and I drink the whole [ __ ] can right
then like I didn't it was just there was
too many you know it's that young time
in your life when your chromosomes and
your [ __ ] and your nuts or anything
you know you're nuts aren't even doing
nothing at that point you're nuts or
something you [ __ ] kind of you know
twist around each other like this little
you know there's magic little time balls
or whatever to relax at night before you
go to your bed you know you're nuts or
nothing you're nuts or just a place you
think your body's just storing you know
extra [ __ ] molars or whatever you
don't even know what your nut sack is at
that age
and then you you know you're watching
this TV show when you see a couple kiss
for the first time and you just working
I'm [ __ ] drink nine cans of watermelon
Shasta and just just get ready to piss
in the bed dude it was just that you
know it was your what is it called when
your body gets so fired up about
something that it starts to metastasize
a little bit into something else
hormones hormones and they put them in
milk too and sometimes I'll [ __ ] have
a little milk for I jerk off just to get
back to that old-school feeling but
hormones man that was the thing you know
I'd be sitting there and you know
Stephen and you know um what was the
other girl's name in the show 9:02 one
know Stephen and [ __ ] I don't know Dylan
McKay was the one guy he was the fancy
guy he was like the Fonz he came in with
the jacket and he never kind of said
anything and he he was always too kind
of squinted his eyes and he was always
kind of he came up to the door and the
parents didn't really like him and then
he rode off on his motorbike he really I
think he might have had [ __ ] autism
bro and I don't think he probably
registered that bike because he was kind
of always in and out of this of [ __ ] you
never knew anything about him Luke Perry
his character Dylan McKay and he was in
love with [ __ ] Sandra or whatever
Jennifer Doherty and they would um and
they were always talking about doing sex
and when that [ __ ] what happened bro cuz
you got a picture of man we're sitting
there me and my two siblings and you got
Dylan McCain you got Jenny Doherty they
[ __ ] you know they're 30 in real life
well we don't know what his kids we
think you know cuz I was probably 11 my
brother's you know 13 my sister's nine
we're all sitting there and this is the
program that mom lets us watch that she
maybe shouldn't let us watch but you
know she wants to put a little bit of
lotion on her legs in the other room and
floss her teeth and that's her timing to
be by herself so this is what we get so
we're
sitting there ready to watch Beverly
Hills and I know too one knows boy and
and then they start talking about sexual
or you know somebody [ __ ] you see a
little bit of a bra strap and next thing
you know I got a [ __ ] lay it out of
my bag dude cuz I don't know what's
going on because my hormones are
sternness just mingle around my body and
get to know each other you know and
suddenly my burnt my brain is starting
to say hello to my dick but on the
inside of my body and this is before
this like an internal tender and
everybody's [ __ ] swiping right and
it's just crazy you're by your neck
starts [ __ ] tightening up and your
dude I remember sometimes my arms would
go straight out to both sides of my body
for no reason I wouldn't even know it
was happening because on the screen they
had these young people and you were
feeling just sexual and we're feeling
keyed up and jacked up on your own these
little crystals man cuz God puts these
little [ __ ] crystals in your body when
you're born I guess and they don't
really kind of sprout until you start to
get sexual and that's hormones and when
those [ __ ] start popping off it's
like man it's like there's flavor
crystals and gum it's like you think
it's just gum and then BAM you hit that
[ __ ] and suddenly you know suddenly you
have diktats your dicks got fresh breath
and it's that kind of thing
that's them libido poppers though them
internal hitters and that's kind of what
happened when I would see these shows
we'd sit there and I would get I didn't
I I didn't even know really what was
going on I just my brain would I
couldn't close my eyes or blink and I
would just [ __ ] drink two cans of
Shasta you know man I feel exhausted
even thinking about it now